So who's my guest this week?
It's the inventor of the World Wide Web,
Sir Tim Berners-Lee.
When it comes to computer science,
it doesn't get much bigger
than inventing the web.
Not many developments
have had such an impact
on the way we live
and arguably the way we think and behave.
His former boss's initial
description of his idea
as 'vague but exciting',
might seem modest now
but that's an indication
of the unforeseeable change it created.
Tim Berners-Lee has devoted his time
to advocating web freedom,
and access through his
World Wide Web Foundation.
Now he wants to challenge the power
of big organizations online
and reassert the web's
original principles.
But is it too late?
Here's a taste of what's coming up.
How happy are you with the digital world?
Recent events and including the pandemic
has heightened people's
understanding out there
that this is not just,
it is a right but it's not something
you can take for granted,
you have to fight for it.
When I've seen you,
when I've been actually
face-to-face with you,
with your creation
and there's only one that
really comes to mind,
which was your cameo
in the London 2012 Olympic
Games Opening Ceremony.
You were on stage in an amazing
looking sort of lit up house
and you look like you're typing,
and then a message appeared
across the audience,
beamed across the audience which said,
"This is for everyone."
How did that feel doing that?
And you know being on that showcase.
It was beeping amazing.
Sir Tim, welcome to the program.
It's lovely to have you here
and we're gonna come to your
latest project very soon,
but I wanted to ask first of all,
is it a burden being Tim Berners-Lee,
the man who invented the World Wide Web?
I wouldn't say it's a burden.
It doesn't seem from my
point of view to be a burden,
in that I'm not that famous
for people recognizing me
in the supermarket.
On the other hand inventing
the World Wide Web
means you do get invited
to all kinds of great dinners
and meet all kinds of people.
So my life gets more interesting,
just for that,
so I'm not a burden.
And I wonder for you,
is there a pressure with it sometimes?
'Cause when, I don't know,
if I was sat next to you at a dinner
and I asked you what you do?
And you say,
of course what you're working on now,
oh I happen to invent this thing called
the World Wide Web.
Hm-mm.
Do you feel a pressure
then to talk about
things you've done since,
or how that compares?
I've learned from bitter experience that
it's a good idea to say early on,
by the way I invented
the web 30 years ago.
Just about that small thing
Get it on the table.
rather than spring it after
five hours of conversation.
So that,
but I think there's certainly,
you know when we started
the Web Foundation
there was a feeling that you
can't just invent something
when it gets to the 20,
the point that 20% of
the world is using it,
then there is a responsibility.
And so it wasn't just me
but all the people involved in
making the web more powerful,
realized that every step they
made the web more powerful,
the gap in power between those who had it
and those who hadn't was increased,
so the digital divide was increased
every time we made the web better.
And so that meant we had a,
the Web Foundation was founded basically
partly on simply if 80%
of the web at the time,
of the world wasn't on the web,
then we should,
the other 20% has a duty.
Yeah.
To get them on work,
to get them on,
now it's more than half
the world is on the web.
So it's saying,
we've got lots of momentum
in that direction but,
yes I think there's a
responsibility both for getting
the other people on,
but also then particularly
in more recent years
realizing that it's not obvious
that the web will actually
be a hundred percent a good thing.
And actually what you also
have to constantly be looking
for what could go wrong
and what has gone wrong
and what could be fixed.
How happy are you with the digital world?
Stepping back very much in general,
I think you can't complain
because, and I think the pandemic,
I think has shown a lot of people
who didn't really think
about it beforehand,
that actually you know,
if they have the internet
they can work from home,
if they don't have the internet
then they can't
work from home.
Hm-mm.
And then maybe people also think
a little bit more about the fact that
there hasn't been very much
censorship in the country
where they live,
but they look and they see
that people in other countries
have the internet blocked
completely during elections,
for example, and so on.
So I think that recent events,
including the pandemic have heightened
people's understanding out there
that this is not just,
it's the internet is a right,
but it's not something
you can take for granted
you have to fight for it.
Yes, and the fight for
the rights of information,
but also the correct information,
free information,
not fake news.
Hm-mm.
And not have that layer on it.
How do you think we're doing with that?
'Cause some would say the
internet has made things better
in many ways,
but worse on some of those fronts.
I think it really depends on
which system you're talking about.
So different social media systems
are designed to work in different ways.
You could like things
and the like buttons,
and the poke,
sort of the workflow you go through
to encourage each other and
give feedback to each other
is different.
And it turns out they have
very different effects.
So it turns out that early on
feminist bloggers found
that being on Twitter
was just horrible, for example.
And, so other than,
the questions about being on Instagram,
if you're a teenage girl it can be,
it can have psychological issues
just with the things that
the platform seems to do,
suggest that you should do.
Hm-mm.
That you have to be infinitely beautiful
and things like that.
So these are all different platforms.
So it's not the web as a whole,
it's a question of
the design.
Of what's been built
on top of it?
Of the platforms, yeah.
So what I tell people is look,
you know, to start with,
if you're a coder,
whether or not you're a coder,
if you can imagine a social
network that works differently
and you think it would work
and you can imagine it would work.
It would be a better place to be.
Or maybe you can imagine
a social network which,
where people would tend
to be more constructive,
where you tend to get more
truth out of it than untruth
because people be more
collaborative and more,
it'd be,
have a better culture then,
then design that social network.
But do you-
Or go to the people.
But that sounds like you believe
design could be the answer,
and that it can be a
better world can be baked
into the design rather than
what some people say which is,
'These platforms reflects back
at us, the societal ills.'
So it's not the platform's fault,
it's who we are.
And therefore they don't
think the technology companies
should do more for instance,
to get rid of the toxicity
that many women find online.
I think that's,
it's naive to imagine in a way
it's simplistic to imagine
that things like Twitter
and Facebook and Instagram,
and so on, and Reddit.
That they are simple mirrors.
Initially, I think when the early,
maybe we sort of,
in the pre-web days when
people were using internet
to exchange files,
the meme was that the internet is neutral.
The humanity out there
is good and bad.
Yes.
When you connect to people you know,
you could join them in an
IRC chat room back there
before the web,
and you would find good and bad people.
But actually now because we
have these different platforms
and because they're different,
actually no,
the Web Foundation in
fact did some studies
and looked at when they were
looking at misogyny online,
they were looking at gender rights
and online gender violence.
And they found for example,
three things where a social
media company could actually
change the way the system worked
and it would make it better for women.
And they went to those different companies
and they suggested it
and the changes were made
and the web got better.
So there is a huge response.
I'd like to feel
some of those changes
that you're talking about.
Maybe it yes,
maybe they didn't fall a
huge apples right next to you
but the messages really that the way you
design it is important.
Yeah.
Humanity is important too.
So when we do,
everybody needs to help.
So governments need to help by
getting the laws in place,
things that are really, really nasty,
and illegal,
that are illegal.
Yeah.
People need to,
before they retweet something,
before they like something,
they need to also learn to
actually do a double take.
But would you agree that it's gone,
it's going the other way?
'Cause I always envisioned,
and I used to work
as a technology correspondent.
Hm-mm.
That our offline sales
and our online sales
would come closer,
as we got more used to
using these platforms,
we would try and not do something online
that we wouldn't do in real life.
And yet we seem to have done this.
We project an image of who we want to be.
And because of people
being able to be anonymous,
they are doing different
things than they would do
if they saw you in the street.
So what you're talking about when you say
when you talk about
people being anonymomys
and maybe you're talking about Twitter.
Maybe you're not,
you're not talking about.
Or in the,
in the comments below articles
or on videos,
on this video you know,
people can say whatever they want
but they wouldn't say it to your face.
I think basically stepping back
each of these, the things which go wrong
with each of these spaces is depends
on the way they're designed
that and they,
and in each case the issues are different.
In each case you need
to do lots of research
to understand exactly how the badness
and the goodness propagate.
So you can maybe amplify
the goodness a bit.
So yeah,
I still believe that
being responsible online
is part of it.
Yeah.
You mentioned the World
Wide Web Consortium
of which you're a Director,
the plan and the goal is obviously to hold
Big Tech companies to account,
but there has been concern
because of how it's funded
with Big Tech,
helping to fund it
that there is a conflict of interest
and I suppose taking a step back,
there is a concern about who marks
these few tech giants homeworks',
who does hold them to account.
When we have so many governments
who aren't tech savvy at all.
It's true that we need to get many more,
many more coders into
positions into parliament
and into the judiciary.
So we do need more but,
but if you asked particularly about WC,
WC is a consortium of different companies,
where there are huge companies,
there are a lot of big companies,
and there are lots of startups
and there are big companies,
there's everything in between.
There are academics,
and academic institutions
and the nonprofits,
and they all meet
and at the end of the
day every organization
no matter what it's size gets one vote.
So you can't say,
so no matter how much
money people pour into it,
that they might for example,
in the mobile web initiative,
everybody wanted to get
the web onto mobile.
So 'cause some companies said,
"Yes, we're gonna put my
money into this for the,
the accessibility web
accessibility initiative."
Some companies specifically fund that,
but there's a very, very strong culture.
But once the consortium has
been funded by its members,
then it operates as an independent body,
which is independent.
I spoke,
and I think that's a
very valid point to know
about how it works.
But I suppose I'm also asking
a slightly bigger question which is,
do you have faith in those
big technology companies?
You know,
the Apples,
the Googles,
the Facebooks,
I mean they've got
different parent names now,
but you know, 'cause
they own several brands,
but just use their household names.
Do you have faith that they
can be brought to task,
that they can be policed
and change their behavior?
I know that,
so I'm not gonna talk about
the individual companies.
Fair enough.
In general, and so if you
talk about big companies,
then I know one other thing I
have said consistently is that
there's always a problem when
something becomes a monopoly,
whether it was Netscape
was the only browser
that you could buy.
I remember that.
And then it was Microsoft the
only browser you could buy,
and so on so,
and when, and so AltaVista
was the only search engine
and so now it's,
so whenever you do get a problem
that one company's dominating the space
that tends to be, the
monopoly tends to mean
it's not good for innovation because but,
if you're just starting as another company
it's hard to imagine how
your ideas can have impact.
So yes, I think that you have a,
so in a way there are always
problems with monopolies,
although the market system tends
to take us always naturally
towards that situation.
Then, but the state of whether individual,
I'm not gonna go into
any individual companies,
to what extent I expect them
to behave better or worse
in the future.
But everybody's asking that question.
You're not the only one.
You're the Chief Technology Officer
of a company called Inrupt,
which has this new platform
for the web called Solid.
What is it?
And what are you hoping to do?
Because part of that is about
changing people's behavior.
So Solid is if you like
from a point of view
of inventing the web 30 years ago,
the web it's a midpoint
correction to the web.
The web was, looked to be,
people were very hopeful
about the web.
Then as it's continues
for a second decade then,
and the last decade which seems
to potentially be heading in
place towards all kinds of,
potential things that could go wrong
with humanity using
technology connected and so,
this is an idea about wait a moment
what if we do some bit of a rethink,
for example,
when you work on with one
social network on one,
one website,
everything you've done
there gets stored there,
all the photos,
all the likes get stored there,
on Flickr, and if you're on Flickr,
I've got my, these photos
and I can't share it
the system doesn't let me
share my Flickr photographs
with my LinkedIn colleagues
and my Facebook friends,
because we haven't exported,
we don't have interoperability
between the groups.
We don't have the ability of
a Google group to work in,
but in Facebook.
And Solid is about saying,
"Okay, let's fix those."
So if you log in with Solid,
then you have a Solid ID which
works all across the web.
I can take photographs,
and put them into my Solid storage
into my Solid pod we call it.
A personal online data.
So that's what you are
calling them pods?
These digital.
Yes.
These digital pods.
Pod, yeah.
You know, just wanna try to imagine it.
And so when.
It's like,
if you imagine it,
it's like a USB drive in the sky.
Yes.
It's just a place you can put stuff.
And can you actually do that?
You know, these walled gardens are set up
because they're making money.
That's how the brands want them to be.
And a lot of people conversely
are happy to use them
because they're used to it now.
And they think well,
this is how you use these platforms.
How are you gonna change behavior
and get people
to think like this?
We're not gonna wait
for everybody to change over immediately,
at one point.
We're just gonna start people using,
as people use the Solid platform,
it's enabling of people.
When people realize that
they spent a lot of time
working between different
communities for example,
then all we need is
enough people bit by bit
to start using it
and to realize it's better.
Are you doing this
because you're frustrated
with how the digital world
has become?
Yeah.
These separate-
I created the web because
I was frustrated with how
the digital world was.
'Cause then it was the,
you had documents
sitting on discs.
Yes.
The discs were on computers and computers
were connected to the internet,
but you couldn't just click between.
It's a pretty,
it's a pretty great
invention if I was frustrated
with something I just came up with
the World Wide Web because I
was annoyed about floppy discs.
So, well I can imagine this actually,
no it could be much more powerful,
it could be a,
I should be able to click between
these documents.
Yes.
Instead of having to
download them all separately.
So you-
I love, I love that-
You find, you just.
That it was born from that.
I'm glad you like it, go ahead.
Any time be my guest.
No, but regardless
of the platform you are
actually just saying
to people think about this differently.
Think about your data.
Yeah.
Think about how you are being used.
Yes.
And imagine how it is difficult,
with the web it's difficult,
with the Solid, it's difficult,
it's difficult,
it's a different,
it turns the whole world of
apps on sort of upside down.
Or the right way up, frankly.
So the right way up is,
yeah of course, every
time you do something.
So when you go to,
you go to have a vaccine,
a vaccination and you,
or you go for a run,
or you go to a gym and,
when you go to the gym and
you log on to the gadget
so that it will be natural
that you log on with Solid,
you give it your QR Code,
and you authenticate and you say, "Yes."
These devices in this gym
can write all my stuff
into my pod.
It might.
Then bit by bit.
But how.
How are you gonna cope if it doesn't work?
Are you good with failure?
The developers around me
are really excited about it.
Hm-mm.
Because for different
reasons it's really exciting
as you're a developer as well.
And so I think that,
you know I would've been except that,
so one way of it going for example,
would be just we start
a little group of people
who just continue to
battle on to build a world,
better world and bit by bit, it grows.
But when we started the company,
in fact, yes of course we
got interest from developers.
Well, I'm sure if your
name's on something.
We got a hundred thousand
people created it sort
of pods very quickly,
but just to try and
understand what it was.
And we got a company got
interest from some big,
from some big companies that
realized that they could,
if they used Solid pod technology,
they would be treating their users better,
and they'd have a better
relationship with their users more.
They've been empowering their users,
but mainly we got
incoming from governments.
I wanted to ask you coming
away from your company,
you say, this is a
mid-course correction.
Hm-mm.
I also like the fact you
describe yourself as a geek.
I always like that.
People owning that word
As a very positive thing.
Yeah.
Are you thinking about also,
how do you think the future of
the digital world we live in
is going to change?
What do you think that looks like?
You know, people talking
now is virtual reality
is the matter where it's gonna be
the whole, the future, and the answer is
well, it's gonna be part of the future
it's gonna be another piece.
There was a time when the web,
the internet wasn't really
fast enough to send movies.
And so movies weren't
really a thing but then
bit by bit the computers got faster
and the networks got faster,
and the discs got bigger and
now movies are a big thing.
And so we're getting with VR,
we're getting new media.
It'll be interesting how I
think you'll be able to slip
between you'll maybe slip
between a movie and the VR world
of that movie for example.
Really.
That's what I hope yeah.
I hope that we'll be able to, for example,
maybe we should have a future
version of this conversation
in the VR world where
we can see each other
really well just like we can.
Where we're not actually
physically face to face,
but then.
Although I've missed,
I've missed this.
The pandemic meant that I have
done so many of my interviews
not face to face.
Yes.
So I don't wanna do what
you've just described,
although it sounds amazing.
But there, a lot of the core
of whether we meet in VR,
or whether we meet through
video or face to face.
The things we decide on,
if we're at our meeting,
the things, the events that
we agree on in the future,
those will be stored,
that data which is data
which we will be able to use
much more effectively,
Then hopefully as we've
as this revolution of.
Yeah.
of personal empowerment
flips the world back
right upside down.
When you have control of your data.
One of the interesting
things that comes out of this
is an AI that works for you.
Talk to your,
you talk to your current AI,
Siri, who do you work for?
Alexa, who do you work for?
If they're honest actually
it's not you,
but imagine Charlie.
I never asked Siri
that question.
What would it say?
I think.
Would it say Apple?
It would've said I worked
for Steve Jobs but now it'll
say, I guess we work for Apple.
Have you ever asked them that question?
It's a good one.
I think I have, but its-
Imagine you have a
Charlie where Charlie says
actually I work for you
Charlie says, you know,
you paid for me,
you get,
you trust me with all
with all your information.
Just the final thought, if I can.
I was thinking when I've seen you,
you know when I've been
actually face to face with you,
with your creation
and there's only one that
really comes to mind,
which was your cameo
in the London 2012 Olympic
Games Opening Ceremony,
and for those who haven't seen it,
obviously millions did,
you were on stage in a,
in an amazing looking
sort of lit up house.
And you look like you're typing
and then a message appeared
across the audience,
beamed across the audience which said,
"This is for everyone."
How did that feel doing that?
And you know,
being on that showcase?
It was beeping amazing.
It was absolutely incredible.
Such a privilege to be,
I mean to be asked to sit in that stadium
with, I mean to be part of the crew
for the Opening Ceremony of the Olympics
was, you know all volunteers,
a few total stars,
total stars that I'd really respected
and you can meet backstage,
and then when I was in that before the.
There's was a house
around you.
The house was around me.
Lifted up didn't it?
And before it lifted up,
I was sitting there
and I had to front myself against
the back wall of the house,
'cause all thousands of
dancers had been dancing,
all wearing different costumes,
all they'd all been wearing,
dancing, different dances.
And they all left the entire
stadium came flocking in
and they all went in through
the door of the house,
and some of them they
all knew where to go.
and they could go left or right,
and up and down,
and they all had to disappear.
And they,
so they came running incredibly excited
and just had the dance
of their lives.
Yes.
And there, and they've
expressed their individuality.
And, but also their common you know,
the commonality of working
together on the Olympic,
on the Olympic Ceremony and
the commonality of working
together for the Olympic Games
So that was just.
Amazing.
Incredible, incredible.
Well and such a powerful message.
You know, this is for everyone.
What you created that must have given you
an amazing feeling.
Tim Berners-Lee,
Sir Tim Berners-Lee,
thank you so much for talking to me.
The pleasure's mine.
And thank you so much for being with us
until we meet again,
stay safe.
Goodbye.